The drive into the
mountains is long and arduous.
So Arde suggests we stop
for a bite along the way.
Fortunately, in Sumatra,
street food is a way of life.
On almost every corner, vendors
hock freshly made snacks from
pushcarts or
hole-in-the-wall shacks,
like this one selling bika,
a tea cake made from coconut.
What is this?
Really good.
It's everyone's favorite.
Everyone's favorite.
Hello.
- Hello.
- Hi.
Nice to meet you.
My goodness.
That incredible
smell, what is that?
They cook the cinnamon wood.
Cinnamon wood.
So this is bika.
Bika.
It's like a cookie, a--
Cake.
Small cake.
So it's almost like
an Indonesian macaroon.
Well, pretty much like that.
So that's a banana
leaf underneath there.
Yeah.
Wow.
And then see
how they close it.
Oh, OK.
Put the pot back
on, and it bakes it.
Want to try?
OK.
Let me take that.
Thank you.
Pew.
Oh.
No, no, no, no, no.
Here.
Damn.
It's like a bird [bleep]
all over my windscreen.
Here we go.
OK.
Oh, no.
[laughs]
Ah, yes.
Oh.
[bleep] Oh, I'm sorry.
It hit the side of the pot.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So can I have a look at
these ones that are cooked?
Let me get the tongs.
Here we go.
[laughs]
Oh, sorry.
[bleep]
See how they--
OK, got you.
How many bika do you make a day?
[speaking indonesian]
2,000.
2,000 bika.
A week.
- No, a day.
- A day.
- Every day.
Stop it, smartass.
[laughs]
They make it look so easy.
They're angling up to eight
beautiful biscuits in there.
Now I couldn't even
get one, so yeah.
I mean, practice makes
perfect, but how many
coconuts do you want to screw?
This is like typical
from this area only.
And people normally
eat this while
having coffee in the afternoon,
like having a tea time.
Mm-hmm.
Excellent.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much.
- [speaking indonesian]
- Oh, my lord.
[speaking indonesian]
Yeah.
My apology for
screwing so many up.
2,000 a day.